I want you to analyze the running time of Dijkstra and ideally, I would just ask you
but given that you can't answer me directly,
I'm going to have to make this a multiple choice question.
And it turns out that you don't have enough information to answer it.
So for you to be able to answer it, what were do you need to know.
So the running time of Dijkstra in terms of n and M and here's a sketch of the algorithm again.
Remember for each node it finds the shortest distance so far--it removes that distance
from the set and then it checks each of the neighbors.
I've got a node that it found the shortest node--it does a little bit of competition--
constant competition for each of those before going up and starting again with another node.
But you will have enough to answer this question--is it because the running time depends
on how find shortest is implemented, is that because it depends on the degree of the nodes
in question or is it because it depends if the graph is dense or sparse.
You'll get a different answer in those cases. So just check which one and I'll give you some feedback.